Turia is with us in Virginia hi Torreya
how are you great day thank you so much
for speaking with me and thanks for all
you do YouTube thanks how can I help so
I have a sign he's 18 he's in college
with no scholarships we're paying out of
pocket so we're not in debt to student
loans or anything like that and the
thing is we had an agreement we have a
contract to say that if he makes
anything below a B he has to pay out of
pocket pay me for paying for the
semester so we check his grades every
semester unfortunately every semester it
hasn't been great and he's been paying
that hasn't been a problem he works and
he's been paying but unfortunately I
mean it kind of backfired because he
still not doing good we thought that you
know by hanpan out of his pocket and
using his money and him being able to
slow some things down that he wants like
his goal is to get a car things of then
naked that you know he would be like
okay I got to do good unfortunately he
still isn't and I just I could use some
godly advice on how what can I do so why
is he not making the grade limit when
you say he's not doing doing good what's
what's amazing is I'm again he's not
make any B C's average he's averaging
out or some classes he's not dropping in
classes in time so he's not making the
grade making B's or C's and it's just
you know I speak tall my Shawn put the
grades in his face so he could see an X
somehow does it make him feel and I
talked to him but he he told me that you
know he he want to do every semester
says I'm gonna do better and he says he
tried but I don't think he try to think
other things his priorities might not be
in order he's not going I mean he
literally he's not a child as out
hanging out or anything like that he's a
really good kid but for some reason I
can't seem to get him motivated to let
him know that this is important we
thought that part what I'm trying to
figure out what why he's not making
great
he's just not motivated to do it
motivate which I mean he doesn't go to
class he doesn't study what's the plan
he goes to class
no I believe he doesn't he even doesn't
study or he progressed and he is a
procrastinator
unfortunately I got a many part data
from his mom but yeah he might study the
day before or you know yes he's
definitely a procrastinator
yes sir and why is he dropping clays
dropping classes when he starts no no no
we never he didn't drop because I would
have preferred that so we can get some
of the money back but he hasn't so he
just went through okay so how many
semesters has he been there I let him
stay in school is been a year it's been
a year to two summers yes sir anyway I
made out of two semesters how much out
of two semesters how many C's did he get
I'm going to tell you Dave he has no
bees no 800 C's and DS and that's it
okay is he is he not intellectually
capable of handling college hmm nice
pretty I think he handle it worse I only
knew as a Community College I'm okay if
he can if he can't make B's in Community
College he's not going to class and he's
not cracking a book at all or he's got
an intellectual issue okay because I
mean what did he graduate from high
school obviously what was his GPA when
he came out of high school it was
average as well he barely managed GPA
maybe 2.9 maybe 3.0 but it was that's
not average that's a 3.0 is a B that's
above that we might have it was he was
close to he's he's capable of passing
these classes absolutely is he living at
home yes sir yes sir okay um where's his
dad in this discussion
unfortunately I've been a single mom so
he hasn't been around okay
are you guys having a church yes yes
actually I got a spirit of faith
I would do I would do a couple things
one is okay I don't think this kids
going to class and I know he's not
opening a book at all okay because a
community college is not that difficult
the bar is not that high if you go in
there and you sit and you listen to the
teacher and you take notes during the
class and you actually read half of the
homework you ought to be making a B and
he's making C's Indies he's not even
showing up yeah
there's something else going on here
that you're missing and I'm missing in
this discussion so I would do two things
one is I want a very structured thing if
you're going to let him go back I want
very structured I want some kind of
proof that he's actually in the class
I'm going to treat him like a juvenile
like he's a youngster because he's
acting like one I think he's skipping
out okay that's why I think he's going
we have a meeting with the counselor
next week on my show so let's some kind
of insurance policy that you can
actually get physical proof that the
young man is sitting in the class number
one number two then you treat him like
he's in sixth grade and you look over
his shoulder and make him do his freakin
homework okay okay because he's not
gotten the discipline that the average
sixth graders got right now their sixth
graders had better study habits in this
kid okay right mm-hmm is he going to
study right and if you're going to act
like if you're going to be a man my son
you have to act like a man and then the
third thing I would do is I do is there
a guy in your church a married couple
that the guy is reasonably successful
academic motivated or somebody that you
know it's got a business or something
that your son could look up to that
would sit down with your son maybe once
a month at your request not a big bunch
of time on his part but just to motivate
him just guide a guy okay yeah I can I
mean there are tons of men and he's in
his man program he hadn't been there in
awhile just because he works in school
but
yeah I can't I got to reach out to them
and yeah I'm not concerned about how
much he works or whether he pays you
back for the see that motivation is not
working he even get his act together you
need to pull all support because you
didn't but then that day that's what I
said I just wanted your advice that's
what I wouldn't do it though right no I
think that way I think you make a good
hard run about putting a lot of
structure around them and support around
him and let's get him on through there
not because academics are important but
because the self control and self
discipline that he learns to cause this
change to happen in his character is
going to cause those grades to come up
that's what's important in this equation
okay and and and I think you try to lay
a carrot out there in front of a guy who
in the horseshit okay he didn't go for
it you know no he didn't elevate him it
you didn't find the right button to
motivate him there's got to be something
else that motivates him right and it
might be treating him like a little
child might might cause him to man up a
little bit I don't know something like
lines but I want him to square shoulders
and step into this and you do too for
his own sake not because you need him to
or I need him to but for his own sake
yeah let's get a guy in his life you get
that men's program in addition to that
into his life let's get physical
confirmation of his physical presence in
the class and then hey I want to see
your notes that you took every night
when you get home from class once in
your notes and then I want see what your
homework assignment is and I want to
watch you do it and you get off the
phone you get off the TV and no you
don't need to work until you get that
done I'll feed you and and no you don't
need to pay me back
what I want you to do right now is I
want you to go to class the way you pay
me back sooner you become a man that's
how you pay me back hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]